do you know that baba bowie did an
appearance where did you do your
appearance this weekend chicago i did my
stuff in chicago saturday night's fine i
get up for my flight on sunday morning
i go to the airport and when i get to
the airport i'm starting to feel funny
my stomach's sort of turning he felt
really sick so
he gets on the plane
he's going from both sides he has to
vomit and make duty no and you're on the
plane and i'm on the plane and he
vomited three times on the plane in the
bathroom
on duty
i was in coach and i can't remember the
guy's name but he recognized me from
united airlines and he bumped me up to
first class if i would have been in
coach i would have absolutely vomited on
passengers because i actually looked in
my thing and there was no uh there was
no bag
you know i was looking for the bag
oh man
that's bad was your underwear messy and
everything it's got to be
you know again i know your ass must have
been raw you know what it was a bad
scene on the plane yeah when i came back
out of the bathroom i realized that i
had vomited all over my pants
but it was too late because i mean it
wasn't like horrible but you could see
there was spackle on my pants right wow
so i was hoping nobody noticed that uh
my my underwear was was you know in bad
shape wow then i got home
what did you do with your underwear when
you got home
you know everything goes right in the
wash then who does that your wife or you
just do it she did it she did it then
the whole day i told her i made in my
pants and you need to wash my underwear
she had this why did you just throw them
out she had this virus a month ago so
she knows what's going on but
but then did she look in your underpants
no you threw it who took the underwear
and put it in the wall she probably
didn't look but she's the one who washed
it
wow but then that night what are you
putting in that wash is gonna make that
all go away is underwear that important
to you that you just don't throw it in
the garbage other things in there no no
mix around with it i know i wouldn't
want my wife to see that it was only the
barf pants and the underwear and then
and then oh this is really bad you're
ready for this uh and then i had to put
the sheets in because
at night while i was asleep something
happened you went to the bathroom in the
bed i mean it wasn't well yeah okay
wow i never heard of that
you know how when you're sick and you
think that there's air like an adult
infant i needed a diaper and you're
right about about me being raw wow is
the worst flight i've ever been on in my
life